so once you finish med school and you
were up and running with a thriving
practice why did this epiphany happen in
terms of making a film rather than just
going and finding an agent and
submitting yourself online and going out
for auditions okay well the the main
reason was I didn't feel I had a chance
to be quite honest so I looked at the
competition and I looked at all these
wonderfully talented people who just are
you know I felt you know they're in a
different league than me um I I kind of
felt like the same way it kind of goes
back to when I applied to medical school
I saw these people around me like super
smart and I was like oh my god I'm gonna
have to work ten times as hard to
graduate from Medical School as these
guys around me and I felt that a hundred
fold when I was my decided to be an
actor you know I looked around I was
like these guys are really talented
they've gone to drama school they've
been in this artistic they've had this
artistic psychology for you know since
they were babies you know some of them
have done Nickelodeon some of them have
done this done that and here i am guy
who knows a whole lot about the human
anatomy but not about you know how to
stand and stand on stage right or left
so that was the main reason i felt like
if i put myself on the same playing
field as these other guys I wouldn't be
recognized and I wouldn't have a chance
I felt like I was too much of an
outsider I felt like I wasn't the
mainstream type of leading character
that Hollywood's looking for so I felt
like you know it's it's not going to
happen the other thing is I'm a
professional and I don't have the time
to go via the normal route I don't have
the time to audition for XY and saying
things that may or may not pan out so
that's when I had to kind of I made the
the reality Kenny look the only
way you're going to make this happen is
if you make yourself stand out somehow
and how are you going to do that and I
felt the best way to do that is to make
something make a film because I know how
to work with people I run a practice I
know how to organize I know how to
manage my time I had a lot of concepts
in my mind thoughts and ideas that I
felt were worthy to put it put into a
screenplay or put into action and so
that's how the decision really came
about was just you know kind of
realizing that you know if I go the
normal route I probably won't make it
you know I you know somebody like you
know you know like these super excellent
actors like you know George Clooney or
some of they can walk into Hollywood and
fine they can audition and they're gonna
get it because they're there i always
feel like these guys there there's
something about him that people will
look at them they're like yeah this
guy's great you know he'd look great in
this role of XYZ and then there's the
other part of the actors that made it
but they didn't make it via the
traditional route it wasn't like they
walked into an audition that like hey
you're the next best thing since you no
wonder bread and we're going to make you
happen they had to they had sort of more
circuitous route and that's the category
I felt I fit in there's a saying that I
like and it says expectations or planned
disappointments and I know that's sort
of a negative take and we're trying to
be a little more positive here a film
courage but I'm just wondering do you
think that's why a lot of people give up
or self-destruct in this business
because of those expectations where it
seems like you're very you said you're a
realist and you you realize that it
could not happen and you just kind of
keep on that path yeah I very much agree
with that it's a it's a tough business
that's the bottom line because you it's
unlike anything else because you're
constantly trying to sell yourself which
in and of itself is kind of weird so
it's very difficult and and the thing is
but to move forward in this you have to
have expectations you know and that's
and that's the that's the conundrum
because how can you move forward as an
actor or a filmmaker without the dream
of making it big and so so that's where
the sort of disconnect occurs because
you have to have the dream but at the
same time you have to say to yourself
like look man the probability of you
making it there is is slim like even now
after two films I'm very much like
probability of me making it slim I still
honestly feel that way and and that's my
that's that's me and but but I had the
dream I have a dream like you know what
I think I can I just have to work harder
and I have to keep trying and so so I
move forward yeah
you